were you the girl that was super popular
in high school
you know i was um sports not that
surprising uh sports and um
i was
uh cocky i was i think i was a little
bit of a jerk you wanted to be
an athlete an olympian yeah and what was
your what was your sport i was um
volleyball and basketball and swimming
and i was best at volleyball but i and i
i think i just because i spent so much
time doing it it occurred to me like oh
i this better be building towards
something this better be something that
i'm going to do in my life you know
because you were goal oriented yeah and
then i realized you know i'm never going
to i may be all right at this but i'm
never going to go to the olympics what
am i thinking i could have gone i could
have played in college and i decided to
go to a college i couldn't play was
there pressure from you your father was
a military guy yeah and i always picture
military guys like you know robert
duvall and um or whatever the hell that
movie was great great i couldn't think
of it
like was everything about if you're
gonna be playing volleyball you better
be the best at it or not i thought i was
like a marshmallow
you didn't feel that pressure no i have
that pressure internally like it just
comes from me right so so when you're
playing volleyball and you're that good
at it
what dissuades you from becoming an
olympian was it an injury or something
i'm 17 i'm a volleyball player i'm a
high school i'm deciding where i'm going
to go to college and i
a realize that i'm gay and b injure my
shoulder unrelated
to you that you're gay i'd like figured
it out through rational deduction i just
decided that must be what it is i was
thinking about it and decided it it was
really good you know by the time you're
like five that you're gay because you're
attracted to girls in your class no i
really didn't figure it out till i was
16 or 17. were you distraught and scared
when you learned you were gay i was
relieved that i had figured something
out it sort of made everything make
sense right and um i was worried that i
was going to have a hard life
and i was also very happy i thought oh
this means that i'm never going to be
living at home with my parents when i'm
30. awesome
i will have to leave
so you don't you seem like an upbeat
person it wasn't one of these depressing
sort of like my life is doomed it's all
over for me no but the sports thing
figured into it because i had to decide
where i was going to go to college
and having figured out that i was gay i
realized i could not live at home but i
had this injury and so if i was going to
go to school on a volleyball scholarship
i was going to have to live at home for
another year because i was going to have
to have shoulder surgery right and i
thought now that i realize that i'm gay
it's not going to work for me to live at
home so i can't go to school on
volleyball scholarship so i'll go to the
better school that i got into where i
can't play sports so i can leave home so
that's why i went to stanford
you